my father was a big football fan to hear
maybe 60,000 people sing it all at once
like a football game not even at a
concert but at the football game and I
think that would be very moving and
touching for it give me a lot of good
[Music]
we were always searching for our own
anthem and finally in 2008 we found it
I was the guy you kick started aiex
using Bob Marley's three little birds as
their anthem Calif City were playing
their final pre-season friendly and
ended up mil nil but after the game they
decided to keep the iyx families in and
I was asked to play some music I started
with Bob Marley three little birds
[Music]
[Applause]
well dancing clapping singing along to
to the side
[Applause]
kind of left that stage of that night
thank you Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody knows song every supporter
knows it's a great feeling when you
enter the pitch and everybody is happy
with the song you see everybody can run
more it's about to fly
[Music]
Kimani gnarly you heard about the three
little birdsong he was so enthusiastic
when he saw all the supporters singing
his father song that he said well man
I'm a supporter for life and I want to
sing it on the pitch yeah my father was
a big football fan you know football and
the music kinda goes hand in hand for
him to be able to hear so many people I
accidentally
after I'm saying three little bird would
mean so much to me not to know that his
hard work has touched so many hearts
that they made it the theme song you
know that's awesome being able to
performance on there to feel the energy
and the vibration in the stadium and
that it did something to me that you
know I'll never forget was moving you
know it was brown shaking a truly
magical moment
that's my team from now on until the day
my number is called